ROWAN MEREWOOD: Talk
to you about here.
Well actually, it's more like
the beginning of the day.
You guys are here
for the Glass demo.
I want to talk about how
you can connect to people--
connect people to the service
that you are trying to write,
to the startup that
you're trying to build.
So the first thing
we'll start with
is this infrastructure
diagram here.
We've got our user on
the side over here,
and we've got your
service over here.
We can tell it's an
infrastructure diagram
because we've got a
cloud in the middle.
Now, what we're trying
to do is build some kind
of link between
those two things.
The traditional way of doing it
is you can build that yourself.
So something you
can build here is
you have a device the user
is connecting to your service
with, and you give
them some kind of token
on the device that connects
them to your service.
This comes with a
number of issues.
Firstly, for your
developers, you
have to implement this yourself.
You've got to maintain the
infrastructure along with it.
You've got to handle
the security issues.
So we're starting to see
way more stories coming out
in national press in terms
of people who either decided
that they didn't need to
encrypt their passwords,
that they could encrypt their
passwords just by MD5ing them,
that they were using
passwords on their own at all.
And also, then you've
got to make sure
that that system works
on every single platform
that you want to deal with.
So we've already got a headache
from a developer point of view.
And as it's been a
kind of recurring theme
throughout these
presentations, there's
a lot of this where
you're probably not
interested in
reinventing the wheel.
You want to go out there and
have new and exciting problems
that no one else
has run into before.
Now, for the humans
who are actually
going to try and use
this application,
it just starts to get worse.
They've got more
passwords that they
need to stick on Post-Its
next to their monitors.
They've got more devices.
So when they're trying to
connect to your service
through multiple devices,
that means I log on on here,
I get my password, I put
it in, I set everything up.
Then I get a new device
and I log on there,
and suddenly I have
to try and remember,
was it the name of my dog?
Was it the name of my cat?
Is it my birthday?
So I put it in again.
And then I've got to do all
of that setup all over again.
And I've got to trust
that you've actually
built a secure system as well.
It just turns into
a massive headache.
So that's hopefully
where we can come in.
So in fact, just a
quick show of hands.
How many people know
what Google sign in
is, or have heard
of Google sign in?
Yeah?
Oh, OK.
Facebook sign in?
Yeah.
Twitter sign in?
So it's all the
same kind of hands.
OK, so with an
identity provider,
this is the kind of
setup that you get.
So what I want you to
do is ignore the devices
for the moment.
What we're saying
is that you will
provide a connection between
you and the person that
is trying to use your service.
So this is what sign in
with Google is doing,
is it's building
this connection here.
So that token that was
previously on the device
now exists off in
the cloud somewhere,
and it just exists once.
Then, whenever people
have a device-- now,
if they've got an Android
device or an Android device
with Play services
installed, they already
have a Google account.
So there's no need for them
to enter their password again.
That means whenever you
get a new device here,
you basically just hook
it into this channel,
and you automatically
get that sign in effect.
You don't have to remember
any other password
other than the password that
goes with your Google account.
And you get a couple of other
interesting benefits as well.
So first of all, this whole
system is based on OAuth 2.
That means it's
fairly open standard.
That means there are a number
of implementations out there
that can help you work with
the basic details of it,
alongside our libraries.
We support across a variety
of platforms, so web, iOS,
and Android.
And then we've got
some special features
that we built on top
of this that I wanted
to tell you guys a
little bit about.
So firstly, we provide
over-the-air installs.
Now, what this
means is if you are
trying to drive
app installations
from various
locations, then we can
provide a really slick
and clean and efficient
way of doing this.
And the other bit is
cross-device sign-on.
So this is a kind
of magical effect
where I just have to
sign in in one place,
and then I'm
automatically signed
in in all these other locations.
And finally, if you're
using any of Google's APIs,
and you want user
access to those APIs--
so for example, if you want
to access the user's Drive,
you want to do something
with their YouTube history--
then you're going to need to
sign them in via Google anyway.
So let's take a look at a
couple people who use these.
So you can try these out
for yourself as we go along,
or when you are somewhat
faster internet connection.
Who speaks Spanish?
Yeah?
Good.
So this example is for you.
So Minub, they do travel
guides for various cities.
Now, if you go along
to their website,
then they've got a
little button up here
which allows you to
create an account.
So I go in.
And luckily, it's just a case
of hitting the big red button,
even if you don't speak Spanish.
So we click that.
And we get the standard
sign in window up here.
So this is another
one of the benefits
of using a sign in provider,
is that your users start
to get used to the
same process each time.
They don't have to learn a
new set of password rules
or wonder whether
you've called it
username or nickname or email.
They just get the same
process each time.
And you can see in here, we're
asking for some permissions
that we want to use to
access their account.
Now, when they click Next
here, because their devices are
registered with
Google, what we can do
is we can detect--
if Minub has an app,
and they've configured
this correctly,
then we know what
devices the user has,
what devices that app
can be installed on,
and whether they have
it installed already.
If they don't, we can show
them this prompt here.
So you can see that
I'm going to install it
on my now rather antique S3.
But I say yes to that.
So I just click through.
And it just says,
it's being downloaded.
So this is the point
where I either come back
to my phone at a later
point or take my phone out.
And you can see
over here that I've
had a notification that it's
been successfully installed.
And then when I
open up the app, I'm
already logged in on the
application over here.
So this is the cross device
sign in aspect of it.
Because when the app was
opened, the first thing
it does, instead of just
displaying the Sign In button,
it makes a call off to Google to
see if that connection already
exists.
If the connection
already exists,
we know we don't need
to show the button then
for someone just to
click it, so they
can do that one-step process.
We can just take
them straight in,
bring all their settings
in, show them their profile.
So this can also work
in the other direction.
So this is quite good if
I've hit your website first,
and I wasn't aware
that you had an app.
But a lot more
we're finding people
are going either mobile
first or mobile only.
So they're not necessarily
going to hit your website
to find out that you
have an application.
They're just going to go
straight to the Play Store
and get it from there or hear
about it from their friends.
So we can do the same thing
going in the other direction.
So Fancy is quite a cool
little web shop affiliate
kind of thing.
They sell a lot of
ludicrously expensive items.
But if people buy those
items, then you kind of
get an affiliate credit for
the links that you supplied.
So inside of their app,
and I sign in with Google.
And you can see that I get
the similar kind of box here.
I sign in, and I've
got my account.
Now, later on, let's say I'm at
work, and it's my lunch break.
So I'm looking on the web.
So I go over to fancy.com here.
And what happens
is the JavaScript,
again, is getting
a callback that's
telling them that I've already
connected to this site.
So they get a little
popup that slides up
from the bottom that
says welcome back.
And then the page automatically
reloads and logs me
straight in again.
So again, this is
really helpful.
If I've grabbed your app
somewhere in the past,
I don't really remember it.
I come back to your website,
and all of a sudden I'm
just signed in on your website
because I created an account
using your app in the past.
Some best practices then about
using these kind of things.
How many people are
building a service that
requires some kind of
login for customers?
OK, so that's a fair few of you.
One of the points
to make, though,
is that user registration action
is a valuable transaction.
It's valuable for
you as a startup
because you're getting a
registered user that you
can then market to directly,
you can track across
all your different platforms,
you can provide them
with a personalized service.
But it's a valuable transaction
for the user as well.
They're giving up
their details to you
so they have to trust you.
They're taking the time to
register in that service
as well.
So they have to understand the
value that they're getting out
by giving you the details
to their application.
So some of the things you
should try and do there.
Don't register the
user until you need to.
So if you're doing a sort of
shopping cart application,
this is a fairly obvious one.
You want to let the user
go through the shop,
buying various things,
filling out their cart.
You don't need to register
them up until the point
that they actually click Buy.
And this as well.
Make sure that the
user understands
the value of what it is
they're signing up for.
And the other thing
that we need to do here
is, you noticed on these
popups before where
I was getting various
permissions for the account.
You can ask for all
kinds of permissions
when you're accessing
the various APIs.
So you can read someone's
YouTube history.
You can ask for permission
to manage their email.
And one of the things you
should try and do there
is only ask for the permissions
that you need at that time.
So we provide a couple
different key ones
for logging the user
in, and they're kind of
in order of the amount of data
that we're giving back here.
If you just ask for what
we call the profile scope,
then that will log the
user in and return to you
as the service provider this
minimum amount of user profile
information that they need
to access the service.
One of the other good things
about this as well is I've been
saying sign in with Google
because one of the more recent
changes we made is that the sign
in service doesn't require you
to have a Google+ account.
So if you just sign in
using the profile scope,
that is anyone with
a Google account.
That means anyone with a
Google Android device, anyone
with a Gmail account, anyone
with a YouTube account,
they can all sign
in using that scope.
You've got plus.login then,
which means that if they have
a Google+ account, you can
access more of the social
networking features that
we provide through there.
And finally, right
down the end, you
can ask for the email scope.
And that's where we actually
provide their email address
back to you as well.
This means that they can
log into your service
and you don't necessarily
need to take their email.
But in a lot of
cases, you generally
want to ask for the
email as well, especially
say if you are adding a identity
provider on top of an existing
legacy sign in system.
Because at that point,
you've probably used email
as an identifier, and you
want to match up social users
to existing legacy users
that you've already got.
Now, one of the other things
we can do though is we
can also do incremental auth.
So you can ask for some nice
basic safe sounding permissions
first, and then
later on, when you
want to do something more in
depth, you can message there
and you can ask for the scarier
permissions from the user
without just throwing a
massive wall of things saying,
hey, sign up for Map, and
let me read your email.
OK, so I wanted to give you two
examples of some people who've
been doing that.
Joilicloud does it quite nicely.
Jolicloud is an
example where they
can ask for a lot of really
frightening permissions
up front.
So they spend a lot
of time messaging
that to you in advance so
it doesn't seem too crazy.
Now, what they do
is they basically
give you this aggregated
cloud storage.
So they provide a nice way
of managing drive files,
YouTube files, I think they
may synchronize with Dropbox
and a couple other providers.
So if you do sign in
with Google there,
they provide their
own popup here.
Well, what you're
doing is you're
selecting from the
various services
that you're interested
in integrating.
So that when you
get to this stage
here, where it says things like
Manage Your YouTube Account,
you already know why they're
asking for that permission.
So if they just gave that to
you as a sort of, hey, sign
in with Google, and it popped
up saying Manage Your YouTube
Account, you'd probably be
asking some questions about,
hm, do I really
want them to know
that I've been watching Miley
Cyrus videos for the past three
weeks?
Now one of the
other things you can
do there is the
incremental auth style.
So Jolicloud just
asks for everything
they need upfront
in one big block
so that they know
that their user is
in the right permit
in the right state.
8tracks then is
a kind of service
where basically they're
streaming music.
And they base this on
doing recommendations
for streaming music for you.
So again, we're
going to sign in.
We've got a basic set
of permissions here.
And then later on
what they can do
is they can use
your YouTube history
to personalize those
recommendations even more.
So if you click over there
on the Connect Your YouTube
Account button, then again you
get the similar-looking popup.
But at this point,
you've only got the one
additional permission
that you're
asking for this
being shown there.
So that's sign in.
You guys look like you're
still awake, so that's good.
Some of the other things I
wanted to tell you about tehn.
We've heard a lot about
the cloud platform.
One of the aspects of the cloud
platform that I feel like kind
of sneaks in the
side is Google Drive.
One of the things that we
can do inside of Google Drive
is you have this
special app data
folder that you can use to
store your application's config
data in the user's Drive.
So the thing that
you can do here,
if you ask for the Drive
app data scope, that
means that you can basically
store little blobs of data.
And you store those in
the user's Drive space,
meaning that you're
using their storage,
and you're using our
bandwidth, rather than
your own infrastructure.
So if you're combining this with
something like the cross device
sign on, then you can make that
kind of completely seamless
experience across
different devices.
So before, for example, I could
be signed in on both my tablet
and on my phone.
But for example, if I
set some preferences
in your app about the theme that
I liked, maybe the news stories
that I wanted to
read, you'd need
some way of either just
letting those be separate
on each device or
syncing them separately.
If you include the
Drive permission,
then you've automatically got
that additional free cloud
storage that you can
use to synchronize
those details across
all of the devices.
The other thing I
wanted to talk about
is once you've got those
users in, you probably
want them to share data with
their contacts, their friends,
their colleagues.
And there are a number of
ways that you can do this.
People are quite
used to this now,
so to do this
effectively you probably
want to be a bit more
sophisticated than just
the kind of standard just
do a dumb broadcast of stuff
out to anyone who
happens to be reading.
Some of the things
that you can do then,
who's developing an Android app?
Oh, OK.
Right.
So some of you are
falling asleep.
That was actually
mostly just a question
to check you're still with me.
One of the things
you can do here,
or if you're thinking of
developing an Android app as
well, a lot of you
have probably seen
that when you go
to share something,
you just click a
button, and you get
this kind of standard
list of applications
that can handle it.
And a lot of the time, this
is not always appropriate
for the user.
Because they'll just have all
of their applications available,
and when I'm, say, sharing
something from the Guardian
app, I'm probably more likely
to share it via different routes
than, say, when I'm
sharing something
from my photo collection.
So what we can do with
the share action provider
is you actually get some
customization over that,
and you can store a file so
that whatever the user used
to share last time will appear
at the top of that list again.
Or you can do your
own customizations
based on their favorite
applications or preferences
that they've set.
One of the other things that we
can do is if you're sharing via
Google+ now, and you've built
that share using our libraries,
then we can actually look
through the user's contacts
and suggest some top contacts
based on who they talk
to the most.
We can pull those contacts
in the user's phone
so that we can give you a
really quick, automatic way
of targeting their
most contacted users
for that particular share.
And finally, one of the other
things we do on Google+ is we
have interactive posts.
So these give you
a more targeted way
of sharing something
directly with the user
that gives them a call
to action on that share,
so they've got something
specific they want to do.
So I just wanted to show
an example of something
that you can do with that.
So here's an
interactive post for why
is Rowan Merewood still talking?
I came for the Glass demo.
We've got a call to
action, which is complain.
So you can post
that to the world.
And then when your
friends see that, they've
got this big action
button, which
compared to a normal
share, we found
this has a three times
higher clickthrough
rate than just sharing
a standard link.
Part of that is possibly
the novelty, but part of it
is also because
you've given them
a very clear thing, a very
clear verb that they're
going to do as a
result of your post.
OK.
A final thing then
before we get some food
and we get some cool technology.
I wanted to kind of hark
back to some of the stuff
that Nick was saying
right back at the opening.
You should be thinking
less about your app
as a discrete thing that
exists as an entire experience
for the user on their phone.
It's less going to be about
the user coming to you
and interacting in just one way.
They're maybe going to open
something on their laptop.
Then they're going to
come back on their phone.
Maybe someone's going to
share a link with them.
Maybe they're going
to be searching,
and they want to come to your
application through there.
So it's very much
about thinking,
how are they going to
interact with my service?
I should not be the one who
is responsible for saying,
you will only interact with
my service in this one way.
You have to go through
this entry point.
You have to come out here.
It's a case of providing
those best entry and exit
points across a variety
of platforms and methods.
You can do this.
So some of the things
you can do here.
Take a look at schema.org.
That's an open standard
that provides markup
for marking up various
entities on your site.
So for example, if you are
a music streaming site,
then there are schema in there
for marking up bands, tracks.
If you are an
airline, then there's
markup for flights,
for destinations,
for tickets, for seating types,
all of these kind of things.
You can also markup
for app indexing.
What app indexing means is
that if I'm on my phone,
and I search for something,
and I include your app name
in there, then I get a button
inside of the search results
that will take me
straight to your app.
Additionally, add
this kind of markup
into your emails as well.
And this is where we start to
process those emails to show
buttons and actions directly
inside of the Gmail interface.
And cards also start to
appear in Google Now.
So if you're interested
in Where, for example,
and your stuff appearing
on Where for free,
then this is a good
way to get into it.
This card idea of
users navigating
through these little cards,
you'll see this a lot in Glass
as well.
This is the concept
that they use.
And finally, really
remember inside of Android
to handle those multiple
intents to have multiple entry
points into your application.
So just to give you a final
few examples on those.
This is what app indexing
looks like if I'm
searching for a recipe using
this site called All the Cooks.
Then inside of here, you
can see that I search,
and there I get the application
that I've got installed,
I open an app button,
and I go straight
through to the application.
One of the things
that we can do there
that is slightly
different to deep linking
is that if you don't
have the app installed,
then we can take you
through to the Play Store
to grab it, and then take you
back to the deep link as well.
So it's another channel to drive
app installations rather than
just deep links into your
applications for existing
users.
And finally, a few examples
of how those actions,
if you markup your email's
content correctly, appear
inside of Google Map.
So at the moment, we can
handle a variety of things.
We could handle flights.
We can display boarding passes.
We can do reservations at
hotels and various events,
and we can do reservations
at restaurants
as well that's a lot.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]